ونحييكم من جديد من طادوا تجسس اشعل ازمه
بين دولتين عضميين واشنطن اعتبرته انتهاكا
وافكين اعتبرت رد فعل امريكا مبالغا في
ولكن من الاساس ما كان الهدف من هذا
المنطاد للتجسس ام انه محاوله لاختبار رد
واشنطن ام هو منطاد ذو طابع مدني كما تقول
الصين وزير الدفاع الامريكي وصف الحادثه
بالانتهاك غير المقبول للسياده الامريكيه
واعلن ان طائره مقاتله من طراز اف 22
اسقطت المنطاد في المجال الجوي فوق ساحل
ساوف كارولاينر كما اعتبرت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه البنتاغون ان المنتظم مخصص
لاغراض التجسس واوضح اوستن ان المنطاد
استخدمته الصين في محاوله لمراقبه المواقع
الاستراتيجيه في الولايات المتحده من
جهتها اوضحت الصين ان المنتظره لم يكن
لغرض التجسس وانه اليه مدنيه المستخدم
لاغراض البحث وخصوصا للارصاد الجويه وان
دخوله الاجواء الامريكيه كان نتيجه
الانحرافه كما قالت عن مساره دون قصد وذلك
بسبب الرياح لتعلن بيكين بعدها اقاله رئيس
هيئه الارصاد الجويه وحملته مسؤوليه
انحراف البالون الى امريكا
الاستخدامات الامنيه والعسكريه للمناطيض
مراقبه تحركات العدو جمع المعلومات رمي
المنشورات الدعائيه
لاغراض التجسس لاغراض دفاعيه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه شهدت استخدام الواسعا
للمناطيد المزوده بقنابل حارقه
تحلق البناطيل على ارتفاعات تتراوح بين 24
وسبعه وثلاثين كيلومترات هناك بعض
المناطيل تصل الى ارتفاعات اعلى
تكلفه المناطيل تعتبر رخيصه مقارنه بوسائل
التجسس الاخرى كطائرات الاستطلاع والاقمار
الصناعيه
مناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من فرانسيسكو
الدكتوره احمد بن نافع استاذ الهندسه
وامنه شبكات في جامعه
الحكوميه اهلا بك من القاهره احمد علي
الباحث في وحده الدراسات الامنيه
والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه اهلا بكما ضيفاي
واسمح لي ان ابدا من القاهره معك استاذ
احمد في الواقع قبل طرح وجهات النظر قبل
الحديث عن اراء كل خبير
عما ينتظرنا او كيف تمت العمليه خلينا
نفهم اولا هذا المنطاد
وما الذي يرصده ما لا ترصده طرق اخرى يعني
نحن لدينا الاقمار الصناعيه لدينا الهجمات
السيبرانيه لدينا عمليات التجسس التقليديه
الذاتيه بالاشخاص هذا المنطاد او هذه
الطرق من التجسس ما الذي ترصده ولا ترصده
بقيه الاليات
بالتاكيد انه المنطاد رغم ان هو وسيله من
وسائل التجسس القديمه عمرها حوالي 230 سنه
لكن بالتاكيد هناك يعني مزايا عديده يمكن
ان هو
تشكل دافع لاستمرار هذا الاستخدام في حياه
الامر من الناحيه الفنيه بشكل اساسي
لانه
ممكن ان هي تتواجد في مدار يعني لا تتمكن
الاقمار الصناعيه من الوصول بشكل دقيق حتى
لو كانت موجوده في نفس المدار لانه سرعته
بتكون اقل والقدره على التحكم في بشكل
اكثر بالاضافه الى انه ايضا صحيح انه
البالون تقليدي لكن الاجازه المحمله على
البالونات في الفتره الحاليه بالتاكيد هي
اجهزه متقدمه فاحنا مش بنتكلم على جسم
البالون بقدر ما نتكلم على المعدات التي
يحملها هذا البالون بشكل او باخر وبالتالي
انا بعتقد انه ليه قيمه مضافه ايضا في
مساله الرصد هناك ايضا قيمه اخرى قد لا
تتعلق بالجانب الفني ولكن تتعلق بالجانب
الامني انه في حياه الامر شاهدنا في خلال
الفتره الاخيره للقدره على استهداف
الاقمار الصناعيه روسيا اجر التجربه العام
الماضي بهذا الشكل ولا تمتحن الامريكيه
اعترضت عليها وبالتالي اصبحت الاقمار
الصناعيه هدف لكن البالونات في حياه الامر
نحن امام عمليه ربما تكاد تكون الاولى من
نوعها لاستهداف بالون طائر في الجو هذا
الشكل في مسافه المفترض ان هي اعلى من
مستوى الطائرات العسكريه بحوالي 15 الف
كيلو متر وبالتالي هذه عمليه نوعيه قد
تعكس الهدف ايضا من استخدامه في حقيقه
الامر حتى فيما قبل شهدنا بعض العمليات
ولكن كانت عمليات لمسيرات مثلا وقيل فيما
بعد بانها مسيارات رصد ولكن في هذا الاطار
دكتور احمد اذا ما سلمنا جدلا بانه بالون
تجسس بانه منطاد تجسس الى حين استكمال
التحقيقات ولكن حضرتك تعتقد بان هذا
المنطاد كما تقول بكين هو منطاد فقط
يستعمل لدواعن علميه ام انه فعليا بل انت
تجسس دكتور احمد بن نافع تفضل الى ان تثبت
عمليه الفحص الاجزاء هذه من شاطئ كرولانا
الجنوبيه والاف بي اي متدخل في الموضوع
هذا عندهم معمل عملاق في واشنطن الى ان
تثبت انها فعلا للتجسس الفرضيه اللي من
وزاره الدفاع واضحه جدا ان هذه التجسس
اضافه اختي الكريمه هدفين
للبالون هذا والمنطاد هذا اولا انه اللي
لفت انتباههم انه فتره طويله كان هذا
البالون على منطقه في مونتانا ودا
المزيد من الوقت او كثير من الوقت يعني لو
افهم معك اكثر دكتور بنافع الى اي مدى هذا
البالون قادر على العمل دون ان يرى مثلا
دون ان يكتشف
بالسؤال سؤال جيد من ناحيه البحث في
الاجزاء المحطمه هذه بعد تفجير البالون
بتاخذها اقل من اسبوع اسبوعين على حسب
التقرير اللي وارد مؤخرا من
الاف بي اي لكن القضيه ما فيها انه لانه
في المجال اللي يتفضل فيه الضيف الكريم
هنا يعني انت تتكلم من 24 كيلومتر الى 37
كيلو متر هذا اللي هو اقل من الاقمار
الصناعيه واعلى من من الطائرات الحربيه
فهو اولا جسم صغير فانت ما بتلاحظه ثانيا
هذا
البالونات مش اول مره يعني يعني بتمر بكذا
مره في في سنوات سابقه وما كان حق بلحظه
اللي خلاها الان فعلا تلفت الانتباه هو
انه ثبت على منطقه محدده والمنطقه دي
حساسه لهم عشان كذا نظروا لها انه حنشوف
احنا ايش المشكله ايش اسم صغير ربما
بالعين المجرده لانه هو
يقدر بما يقارب ثلاث حافلات ولكن ربما
ارتفاعه يمكن او لا يمكن من مشاهدته
بالعين المجرده بطريقه واضحه
استاذ علي هل تعتقد او تميل اكثر كظيفه
بانه هناك شبهه تجسس ام هناك اختبار
للجانب الامريكي لرد الفعل الامريكي يعني
الموضوع
جس نبض اكثر منه تجسس فعلي
يعني
بميل للفرضيتين لانه لا اعتقد ان
الفرضيتين ممكن نفصلهم عن بعض بشكل كبير
بالنسبه لمساله التجسس زي ما تفضل الدكتور
بنافع انه في حياه الامر كان واضح تماما
من الناحيه الواقعيه حتى ان هناك صعوبه في
ان احنا نتصور انه بالونتا في مدار معاني
يمكن ان يصل الى قاعده بلنجز العسكريه
اللي فيها حوالي 100 صاروخ جاهز للاطلاق
من طراز من ثري او ان هو ممكن يعني يتوقف
في هذه المحطه اكثر من غيرها بشكل عشوائي
يعني في حقيقه الامر الفرضيه ايضا
تؤكد انه
الصين ربما ايضا كانت تعلم ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قد ترصد هذا
المنطاد في هذه المنطقه بشكل او باخر ربما
هذه الرساله وهذا ما يقودني الى الفرديه
الثانيه كيف تتعامل معه لانه في الحقيقه
الولايات بتاع الامريكيه يعني يمكن خلال
20 سنه الاخيره وفقا لتقديرات المركز
الدولي للدراسات يعني اسال في حوالي 160
عمليه تجسس معلنه ما بين الدولتين في
العقديه الاخرين لكن هناك زياده بالمعدل
74% وانه في 42% من عمليات التجسس للاغراض
العسكريه صحيح انه كان في خمس محاولات
يعني هذه المحاوله الخامسه الاربعه
السابقه اكتشفتها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لكن كانت اين كانت في مناطق
هاواي كانت في جوان وبالتالي يعني كانت
الصين تحاول ان تستكشف يعني بعض التحركات
العسكريه في مصر هذه المناطق خاصه النجوم
قريب في منطقه بحر السن الجنوبي لكن ان
تصل الى داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وان تصل الى قاعده مونتانا انا اعتقد انه
هذا يرجح النظريه التجسس واراد ايضا انه
الصين تحتاج الى رد الفعل لانه ايضا
القواعد اللعبه انه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تتجسس على الصين هي الاخرى يعني
في العاب
قبل الماضي هي كشف هي في الواقع لعبه
الثنائيه يعني عمليه تجسس من الجانبين
ولكن لا تفضح ولا تقال لانه حتى المتخصصين
يقولون بانه محاكمه
مقصوده ملفات كذلك كل هذه مفضوحه كانت هذه
تبعها الكل تقريبا على كل الشاشات ولكن
استاذ بنافع طيب خليني اخذ مكان الصين
للدفاع على وجهه نظرها طالما انتما
الاسنان اتفقتم على ان هناك شبهه تجسس
شبهه لجس نبض الجانب الامريكي الصين تقول
بانه هذا بالون او هذا المنطاد علمي هذا
منتاج يمكننا من رصد الاجواء وهذا المنطاد
تكنولوجيا متطور لدرجه انه يتحكم بنفسه
يعني تتم
وفيما بعد يتحكم بارتفاع وهذا الارتفاع هو
الذي يسير وهو الذي
يجعله يتبع مسيرته فبالتالي يمكن ان يكون
عن غير قصد
شوفي يا اختي الكريمه يعني هذا عذر الشخص
اللي انكشف يعني وجد نفسه في وضع محرج جدا
بس اضرب لك مثل بسيط شركه جوجل عندها
بالونات زي هذه تقريبا على نفس الارتفاع
في امريكا بتنشر فيها الانترنت في المواقع
اللي ما فيها انترنت وهي نفس التصميم حتى
الاجهزه تبعتها والحجم والارتفاع بنفس
الاسلوب فانت لما تنظر الى انه هل هذه
فعلا يعني للارصاد الجويه فيها كمبيوتر
الكمبيوتر هذا بيوجه البالون حسب الجو حسب
الريح لو هو بدا يزيح عن مجاله وفي اكثر
من طريقه بحيث انك انت تبعدوا عن المشاكل
هذه انا اعتقد ان الصينيه يعني بالذكاء
بحيث انهم يفهموا انه اذا عدى منطقه معينه
لانه كان فوق كندا وبعدين دخل على امريكا
من الشمال حينتبهوله فهم بس منتظرين يعني
ايش حيكون رد امريكا مثل ما تفضل اخي
الكريم يعني ايش حيكون ردهم فيها بس هي في
النهايه هذه وحده في وحده لا ننسى امريكا
عندها كمان طلعت استكشافيه في على تايوان
فيها تايوان وفي الجهه المناطق هذيك فهم
بيقولون طيب انتوا يعني ايش معنى انكم
انتم اوكي واحنا مش اوكي بالطريقه هذه
فهذه قوتين عظمى بتتعامل بالاسلوب هذا
ولكن سيد علي يعني فيما ضيفي يقول بانه
هذه البالونات هناك قدره على التحكم فيها
الصين تقول بانه فقدت قدره التحكم على
هذا البالون او هذا المنطاد وهذا يمكن ان
يكون وارد ما رايك
انا انا اتصارن يعني نسبه انه تكون فقدت
السيطره عليه هي نسبه ضئيله لكن في هذا
السيناريو انا استبعدها تماما يعني كما
ذكرت انه لا يمكن ان تصل الى تلك المناطق
وتستمر في العمل بهذا الامر بشكل او باخر
لكن انا اريد ان اؤكد على فكره انه بالفعل
هناك يعني قواعد للعبه كانت مستقره في هذا
الاتجاه لانه الولايات المتحده كشفت عن
صوامع لصواريخ صينيه في العام قبل الماضي
وبدات تحدد اهداف الصين فيما يتعلق
باستراتيجياتها النوايا وبالتالي هذا رد
فعل واضح من جانب الصين فيما يتعلق بهذه
المساله انها تستطيع ان تصل ايضا الى
الصوامع الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
هناك عامل اخر ايضا يتعلق بالمساله الجويه
الكثير من محللي الارصاد وفقا للتقديرات
الامريكيه اكدوا بانه الارصاد الجويه في
المناطق التي كان يسبح في هذا البالون
كانت طبيعيه تماما ولا توجد يعني تقلبات
فيها وبالتالي من الطبيعي انه هذه يعني
انه لا يمكن فقدان السيطره عليها وبالتالي
ايضا هذا مدخل اخر بالتاكيد
الفكره ولكن ساختم معك دكتور بنفع وبختصار
شديد لو سمحت هل تعتقد بان الصين تعمدت ان
يكشف هذا المنطاد
انا ما عندي خبره عنها لكن هم كانوا
عارفين وكان بامكانهم يبلغوا امريكا قبل
ما يوصل للحدود الامريكيه هم انتظروا
يشوفوا ايش رده فعلهم ومتى بيكتشفون لان
هذه برضو عمليه استكشاف لقدره القوات
الجويه الامريكيه او الغطاء الامريكي انه
متى حيكتشف حاجه زي كذا فهي مقصوده طيب
للموضوع متابعه وللنقاش متابعه شكرا جزيلا
لكم منسيسكو الدكتور احمد بنافع استاذ
الهندسه وامنه شبكات في جامعه سانغوسيل
الحكوميه ومن القاهره احمد علي بالبحث في
وحده الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]